today we're gonna be looking at SCP 1974
object class safe special containment
procedures SCP 1974 is to be contained
in a standard low value item storage
vault at site 242 any d-class personnel
or researchers may perform interviews or
testing with a CP 1974 with permission
from any researcher or senior researcher
working on a CP 1974 description a CP
1974 is a freestanding ceramic bathtub
with a capacity of one hundred and forty
eight point two liters typical of the
kind sold in the United States from the
1930s through the mid-1960s when
recovered it contained 124 litres of
water
any substance added to the water inside
of a CP 1974 will be drained or filtered
out through unknown means if drained SCP
1974 will refill itself at a rate
equivalent to the rate at which it is
being drained maintaining a constant
volume of 124 liters when a subject
makes contact with the water inside of
SCP 1974 they will immediately begin to
hear two voices one voice hereby
designated as SCP 1974 - one has been
described as that of an American male of
about 85 years of age the other voice
hereby designated as SCP 1974 - - has
been described as a male with a thick
Russian accent of around the same age
the former claims to be 1974 while the
latter claims to be the water filling
SCP 1974 SCP 1974 - one and two appear
to dislike each other and are described
as debating constantly the debates
between - one and - - or about
capitalism communism and the historical
and current states of the United States
of America the Soviet Union and China
the following is audio log 1974 - zero
one dr. hull performed an interview with
SCP
1974 - one and - - in that attempt to
ascertain their origin hello would you
do you mind if I ask you something oh no
no no no the Russians who would have
never won if the Cuban Missile Crisis
wasn't resolved maybe if you'd have
gotten an American education instead of
a Russian one
you'd be smart enough not to make comics
like that oh really
the American education system was so
much better than the Soviet one look at
the statistics with the children of the
motherland being so much better at
science you'd hope that we could've won
a war against you Iger discs in fact
with smart Soviet kids and a line like
China how could the Communists not
become the dominant political party I
have some questions about your origin
would you please mrs. communism was
thought up by a deranged crowd who wants
to share when you can get rich like I
washed the people in China are perfectly
happy and would you look at that China
also has smarter kids than the US and a
better economy and a bigger military if
America could stop staring at its
muscles in the mirror
it could try to friend off the impending
communist invasion by China it would in
any way
communism is bound to return to power
all you can do is hope it's like you'll
never be able to escape me without dying
communism will never be able to escape
capitalism America is eternal what are
you saying a lot coming whose fault is
it that you like that remember why would
heal Toby it's because being smart
American thought it would be a great
idea to turn a Soviet POWs into a tub of
water then you thought hey I wonder if I
could be a bathtub will guess what you
can and now we'll both plenty damn it I
think water got dumber from getting
consciousness egotistical s Soviet
savage wasp Oh
yank Ivan I wish I couldn't drained I
wish I could train you
maybe it's sharper ones of your only
company it's worms I hope you'll get
smashed both of you for God's sake
you're a bathtub filled with water why
are you arguing about politics of all
things because we need something to do
but once we agree about something what
else do you two do we talk about how
much we hate you
lard ass so back to debate wait oh no
I'm not done yet
so what you're telling me is that you
just sit here insulting each other and
going in circles arguing about politics
for fun and then when you get bored of
that you talk about me behind my back
now if you'd explain for the new
information I will interview you against
this has been SCP 1974 ending
transmission